okay so it was like this you remember my
Sin City one video and I did that cool
thing with the colors and made the suit
purple and everything was black and
white it was really neat in Sin City ish
yeah I tried that [ __ ] with this shirt
too dick [ __ ] with it for like 40
minutes couldn't get it to work so
apparently a red shirt is that much
different than a blue suit so what you
get today is a lot of red took in your
face sin city a dame to kill for so sin
city a dame to kill for is a sequel to
Sin City it took a long enough holy [ __ ]
took like nine years to get this thing
out immediately makes me skeptical about
a movie when it takes almost a decade
ever sequel come out in any case now we
have sin city a dame to kill for I feel
like I'm gonna accidentally call it Sim
City witch in Sim City who didn't want
to make Sin City and just have it shitty
just like the economy suck the slums
everywhere I'm gonna do that so in sin
city a dame to kill for is pretty much
the same formula as the last sins any
movie you got three stories and they all
make up one movie and this has the
return of some characters it has some
new characters I really like Joseph
gordon-levitt character in this movie
eases gambler he's this really lucky guy
he's pretty suave pretty much Joseph
gordon-levitt playing Joseph
gordon-levitt Mickey Rourke is back as
Marvin he kicks ass again because that's
what Mickey Rourke as Marv does I really
like what they did with Nancy Callahan
in this movie Nancy Callahan the last
movie was like a stripper now she's a
stripper with problems this one she's
badass she did [ __ ] kind of messed up
from the events of the last movie Bruce
Willis is in this movie is hardigan kind
of he's in the background he's like
invisible jiminy crickets almost like
Robert Rodriguez and Frank Miller were
like a Bruce Willis come on signing this
contract be in Sin City too all you got
to do is stand there and say a couple
things it's pretty much your job in the
last die hard movie we know you can do
it we saw Howard booth was bad asking
this movie he was in the last movie but
he pretty much was in one scene at Bruce
Willis his bed he's just saying a couple
things didn't mean to taunting and this
one he's the main bad guy and he's a
dick as much as I like Joseph
gordon-levitt in this movie and his
segments as much as I like Nancy
Callahan in this movie and her segments
as much as I like Marvin this movie in
the segment he's in with Nancy Callahan
as much as I like Josh Brolin's
character in this movie the segment I
cared for the least in this movie was
the Josh Brolin segment which is also
the segment the movies named actors
sadame to kill for segments that's a
bummer when this segment the sequel is
named for is the weakest segment in the
entire movie it's not without merit it's
not without some exciting [ __ ] I like
the fact that they made me ho badass
the first one you always heard like oh
she's so deadly like well she sliced a
couple guys and threw a swastika two
guys armed and cut it off but is she
really a badass is when you're like now
mijo throws down she's badass so really
this segment dragged on I was like all
right the movie is just kind of grinding
down dude not a halt certainly slow
though I felt like the first Sin City
movie even when it was slow was building
to stuff and there was tension in the
room you know he's got to take the dude
the dead guy to the pits and you're like
you hope to get away with it this once
Eva Green being hot seducing dudes and
just kind of she's being hot yeah big
deal get back to the Sin City [ __ ] I
appreciate Eva green being hot as much
as the next guy in come on doesn't
change the fact sadly I walked out of
this movie going if that entire dame to
kill for segments was out of the movie
the movie would have been half as long
it would have been twice as good in the
end sin city a dame to kill for has a
lot of what you enjoyed about the first
Sin City it has its stylistic style in
it and doublespeak when I talked about
it apparently as cool characters it has
badass Reed has kick-ass Erick has some
cool returning characters from the first
movie can Nancy Callahan kicked ass in
this movie it has a really good villain
and it has some cool new characters in
this movie but they did miss the boat in
a couple things where half of the movie
just seems kind of slow and a couple
things in that segment in this movie
were useless you're like all right that
happened and now it's over - involving a
couple cops in the movie you're like
what was the point
it's gratuitously violent it is a fun
movie when this movie has it going it's
really going when the movie slows down
it's really noticeable I will say sin
city a dame to kill for and my best soon
city voice is still a good time to
welcome all required rights sin city a
dame to kill for have you seen it what
did you think about it how did it
compare to the first movie for you
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more